un juicio fuera de lo común grabado para
la historia 14 acusados incluyendo tres
ausentes 100 abogados y partes civiles
durante las primeras semanas el público
revivió los ataques que golpearon a
charlie hebdo en móvil y a un
supermercado coche en parís una vuelta
atrás que resulta insoportable para los
sobrevivientes y los familiares de las
víctimas ves a hombres muy decididos
gritando alláhu akhbar
y sentimos que están determinados a
matar asimilamos
en el día 23 del juicio asombro en las
filas del tribunal un ataque con hacha
se cometió cerca de las antiguas
instalaciones de charlie hebdo hiriendo
a dos personas después de un mes y medio
de debate al irish a pola el principal
acusado es escuchado por primera vez se
sospecha que el amigo de américo olivari
ayudó al terrorista a planear el ataque
al mercado kosher que le costó la vida a
cuatro personas los familiares de las
víctimas tenían grandes expectativas de
este primer testimonio francia entra en
su segundo encierro la audiencia se
suspende tras el descubrimiento de tres
casos positivos de kobe 19 entre los
acusados pospuesto dos semanas la pausa
finalmente duró un mes mientras alien y
sapo la presenta síntomas persistentes
de coronavirus
ya había una posibilidad muy alta de que
en un juicio tan largo se produjera este
tipo de catástrofe para los acusados y
mi cliente en particular en los debates
se retoman el 2 de diciembre con el
ibiza pola en el banquillo de los
acusados el 8 de diciembre después de
las 10 horas de audiencia los dos
fiscales generales piden sentencias que
van desde los cinco años hasta cadena
perpetua para el yaris a pola de los 11
acusados presentes todos niegan
cualquier implicación en estos ataques
que marcaron al país